- Un groupe détendu
à la veille de jouer
sa survie à la Coupe duttttttttt
à mettre le ballon dans
le filet, ce qui at t t défaut
dans le match de mercredi,
qu'ils ont dominé. La sélection
canadienne se  la Croatie.
Il n'y a pas si longtemps,
disputer un hhh
d'une telle envergure
relevait de la science-fiction.
Les jochchchchchchchchchchchchc.
Par contre, la déclaration
d's-match mercredi
du sélectionneur canadien
continue d'être une distraction.
Il n'y sisisisi longtemps,
disputer un match
d'une tell
relevait de la science-fiction.
Les joueurs cas s s s réalisent
tout le chemin parcouru.
Par contre, la déclaration
du sélectionneur canadien
continue d'être unrarararaction.
Il avait dit à ses joueurs
d'aller botts s s s s s s s s sr
leur défaite cruelle.
Une sortie perçue par l'équipe
et la presse croates comme
maintenant d'éviter la question
pour ne pas en r
"Ma conjointe vous en veut,
lance-t-il à la blague
je parais moins bien
que ça en personne."
La sortie frondeuse
de John Herdman reflète
de la jeune sélection,
e e e e e en ses moyens.rororore
que le Canada n'est plus pris
à la légère par les grandes.
Les Croates s'attendent
d'ai
très difficile dimanche.
Les Croates s'attendent
d'ailleus difficile dimanche.
C'est une tâche colossale
qui attend l'équipe canadienne,
qui n'a jamais inscrit
dans son histoire
à la Coup......
La Croatie, finaliste
du mondial de 2018, peut
alignement de la planèteieieiei.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canad